depuis ce matin les questions à plein
régime
c'est déjà l'heure du rush de midi pas
le temps de souffler pour les employés
de cette cafétéria
on n'a pas une minute à nous c'est non
stop stop stop stop et ça fait plaisir
ça fait plaisir de voir beaucoup de
monde comme ça c'est cool selon je
travaille ici depuis dix ans elle sait
qu'il faut être efficace pour servir les
3000 clients du jour venu s'offrir une
pause déjeuner en arrêtant on n'arrête
jamais ici non n'arrête jamais il ya
toujours du monde c'est vrai mais c'est
bien l'air de la chapelle est très prisé
des automobilistes
idéalement située à deux heures de paris
elle offre à tous les vacanciers une
halte synonyme de sécurité
on a acheté juste des sandwichs on va
repartir assez rapidement non c'est pas
du tout installés dans les restaurants
dont contenant oui on profite voilà on
mange un petit beau soleil et on
continue on stresse pas on a une semaine
on est là pour profiter c'est les
vacances
grâce au week-end de pâques l'ère de la
chapelle voit son activité multipliée
par 5 pour accueillir les clients dans
de bonnes conditions tous les postes ont
été doublés un bon test pour préparer la
saison d'été c'est un week-end très
important et ça lance la saison d'été
on doit être prêt pour accueillir les
clients on a démarré ce matin 4 heures
du matin pour pouvoir commencer à cuire
toutes nos mines et nasri croissants
pains au chocolat être ouvert à 6h prêt
pour accueillir beaucoup de monde les
gens sont partis de bonne heure il fait
très beau donc ils profitent de leur
week-end de toutes les aire de
l'autoroute a6 la chapelle est l'une des
plus fréquentées plus d'un recul deux
millions de vacanciers ont fait une
pause ici en 2018